[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We've selected
10 tips to help
you get ready to
launch your news app,
and start gaining readers
as effectively as possible.
1.
Test on real devices and
identify early issues.
Your readers are
consuming your news
on a whole range of
smart phones and tablets.
So it's important to test
with as many Android devices
as possible, in order to
flag and fix any issues.
The Pre-Launch Report in the
Google Play Developer Console
identifies crashes, and
displays issues and security
vulnerabilities.
The report is powered
by Firebase Test Lab,
and is generated every
time you upload and publish
an alpha or beta APK.
You can also use a
Firebase Test Lab
paid offering if you
want to run customized
testing across a wide
range of devices,
even the ones that
are hard to come by.
2.
Run alpha and beta tests.
A new app or update
that readers love
gets good ratings and reviews
that help drive more downloads.
By sharing your app with readers
through alpha or beta tests,
you can gather feedback
on potential issues
without affecting the app's
public ratings and reviews.
You can then fix any issues
before the public release.
A great way to build
your beta user community
and engage your loyal
readers is to invite
people who've left you a
review in the Play Store
by sharing the sign-up URL.
3.
Release your updates in stages.
We know you have
a large audience,
and your brand
integrity matters.
Google Play staged
roll-outs help
to catch any outstanding
issues not found
during testing by progressively
rolling out updates
to a small percentage
of readers.
This means if you
catch any issues,
you can halt the rollout.
4.
Reply to reviews.
News readers can be quite vocal.
Use this to your
advantage to build loyalty
and engage your audience.
App reviews often
contain valuable feedback
and suggestions for
improving your app.
So read them regularly.
Replying to reviews
engages your readers.
When you respond to
negative reviews,
try and indicate how and when
you'll address the feedback.
Moreover, you can take advantage
of the Review Analysis reports
in the Developer
Console to see how
users review your
app in relation
to specific categories.
The two reports,
Benchmarks and Topics,
analyze how each topic impacts
your overall app rating.
5.
Monitor your crash reports.
Google Play collates
information about your app,
and makes it available in the
Google Play Developer Console.
If your app crashes,
you'll be able to see why
and fix the issue quickly.
You can also use
Firebase Crash Reporting.
6.
Run experiments on
your store listing.
When users open
your app's listing,
they'll almost instantly decide
if your app meets their needs.
Unique icons, a short,
to-the-point description,
and good quality,
relevant images
showing your news
home page and articles
will grab their attention.
You can use store
listing experiments
to help find the best
combination of these elements.
7.
Drive "over-the-air"
installs from your site.
Sign readers in with
Google on your website.
Then offer the option to
install your app over the air.
In the Google Play Developer
Console, create a project
and register your
website and app clients.
Add the app installation
prompt to your website sign-in.
8.
Link users straight into your
native app with App Links.
Users following web
links on devices
are frequently presented
with confusing choices.
Tapping a link often
results in the system
asking the user which app
should handle that link.
Use the App Link extension to
ensure that deep links open
in your app.
Use also the Chrome
native app install banner
on your news website, so that
readers who don't have your app
installed, and are directed
to your website from a share,
can easily install your app.
9.
Optimize for word-of-mouth
growth with Firebase invites.
Word of mouth is one of the most
effective ways of getting users
to install your app.
Use Firebase invites to make
it simple for your readers
to send content to their
friends over both SMS and email.
It ensures that referral codes,
recipe entries, or other shared
content gets passed along
with the invitation.
No cutting and pasting required.
10.
Get your app in Google search.
Having your app's content
included in search results
exposes it to a huge
potential audience.
Use app indexing to surface your
branded app's install button
in search results, and
make it easy for readers
to acquire your app.
Head over to Google
Play Developer
Console to start taking
advantage of these features.
If you want more tips on how
to improve your news apps
and build a better
mobile business,
check out the other
videos in this series,
and download the News
Publisher's Playbook.
[MUSIC PLAYING]